all right the animal foundation has a
unique offering for this Valentine's Day
H Mills um this is um it's for love and
not love yes I'm all over this one I saw
it on their Instagram page and it just
made me laugh so for 10 bucks you could
send someone a love you know A love card
just absolutely adorable Happy
Valentine's Day you know the the usual
schmooze but maybe you don't like
someone so much and you wish that they
have a crappy Valentine's Day well for
fifteen dollars the animal foundation
will put that person's name on a litter
box and well cats will do what cats do
but it doesn't end there they're gonna
take a picture of it and email that
person with a picture of their name on
that cat box if you'd like to do that of
course it's all in support of the animal
foundation I think the cats might be
behind it too and and the second option
is five dollars more than just saying I
love you the second option is more
expensive yes as it should be all right
they got to pay for the cat litter so
you're saying love is cheap
Love Is Free